I always like that you got naked it was
something bold about it one time I
remember my brother was out visiting me
in Vegas okay who's on tonight your
Marquee was out the front we go I know
this guy
I know this guy will come and watch him
and you just had your dick out and was
sitting on the lap of some fat person in
the front row and then my brother's like
a closer this is your friend is that I
go I know him
the worst one I had was this I was at uh
Caroline's and I closed with this thing
where I got naked right it ate it worse
than the jokes it's seemed desperate so
I gather up my clothes right and I'm
walking toward the back and I see
somebody leaning against the wall in
front of the Green Room it was Chris
Rock naked
not naked and he looks at me and he goes
what are you doing man oh and I remember
going I don't know and I walked in the
Green Room Chris Rock always says
everything twice what are you doing what
are you doing